bonjour mr à judicaël je suis le
directeur des centres beau institut de
la réunion aujourd'hui nous n'en avons
trois qui sont situés à saint denis à
saint pierre et à saint gilles ça fait
dix ans que nous sommes en activité de
la réunion donc aujourd'hui on essaie de
mener à l'excellence le métier de la
coiffure en associant donc les
techniques traditionnelles et les
techniques haut de gamme que nous
ramenons donc de par nos voyages de par
le monde aujourd'hui mais institutions
spécialisées dans tout ce qui est
extensions de cheveux tout ce qui est
lisse à agen donc les cinq japonais
brésilien correa et américains donc les
clients sont de plus en plus exigeant
donc nous aussi on se donne une exigence
de notre travail afin de leur proposer
régulièrement des techniques nouvelles
donc aujourd'hui on en a importé une
nouvelle technique qui s'appelle les
ciseaux 3d donc on a découvert en taïwan
donc aujourd'hui mais instituts sont les
seuls à l'île de la réunion et en
laissant indien proposer cette technique
là qui est une combinaison de ciseaux
qui associe trois paires de ciseaux avec
lequel on peut couper les filets et des
gravats y aura 5 au titre à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je suis à la recherche de
plusieurs profils dans le monde de la
coiffure dont je recherche des
coiffeuses confirmer donc afin de
pouvoir renforcer mes équipes à saint
denis et à saint pierre donc les
coiffeurs noppen obligation d'avoir des
spécialités non les formera sur les
techniques qu'on maîtrise dans les
salons beau institut donc aussi bien sûr
tout ce qui est extension et lissage
donc le profil recherché c'est vraiment
des personnes qui sont passionnés qui
font vraiment la coiffure avec la
passion et qui cherche à évoluer dans la
coiffure donc à évoluer à apprendre des
techniques nouvelles donc en permanence
donc coeur et je suis aussi à la
recherche d'apprentis dans des personnes
qui n'ont aucune de formation dans la
coiffure donc là on va les prendre en
main on va les former avec l'autre sont
deux formations qui s'appelle la vintage
académique et à saint pierre donc on
pourra les préparer en bp coiffure et
ans et a fait quoi furent donc pour tous
ceux qui sont intéressés n'hésitez pas à
nous contacter bonjour je m'appelle
idiart je suis coiffeuse chez hbo
institut j'ai commencé en tant que
apprentis en 2004 safé aujourd'hui dix
ans je suis responsable de beaux
institut de saint denis à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je serais très heureuse de
partager mon expérience avec des
nouvelles techniques que tels que l'eau
ciseaux 3d les techniques de lissage
avec des nouvelles collaboratrices